[Music]
you are serving up some fashion tonight
yeah stop it
go away tell me more tell me more now
wait a second i was expecting a bump
tonight because you know the baby
i had to suck my belly in today the baby
is very much here and we'll be here in
five days
yes give us a tease of what's to come
because honey you've been teasing us
with these exercises with the bump uh
snacking with the bump life with the
bump so what can we expect with this
baby you're delivering on the 17 this
baby is going to be a world changer this
baby let's just call it my debut album
which is coming out september 17th going
by it um yeah yeah yeah so much to our
power on this album and all the
collaborations you've done lately elton
john miley cyrus megan
cyrus megan how are you doing this i
actually what do you say to these people
i'm just like please please and thank
you hop on this song and it happens
he's recently called you his hero when
you hear something like that is one of
the nicest people ever yeah it's one of
the kind of souls tell me about this
outfit because i feel like it's a little
elton inspired tonight this outfit hmm
i guess 200 degree right right i want to
like kind of mix that like a mask and
film you know kind of you guys you got
to see what i'm trying to give out here
i don't want to nip slip honey we might
have to blur that out for television we
got to keep it family friendly sorry
about that sorry mom sorry dad um what
can we expect from your performance
tonight performance is going to be
really sexy
shocking i want to say yes shocking i
don't want to say shocking i hate
because i'm getting tired of hearing
that word will this be a bma moment
because the vmas are known for moments
it's going to be a vma moment okay
and what about your nominations how are
you feeling about that i'm really happy
to like win all these nominations and um
you know i'm going on stage with jack
harlow
[Music]
jack what has it been like collaborating
step on don't step on the the okay you
can step on it jack you jack harlow what
has it been like collaborating with this
genius over here
you don't want me to say it dude
let's go let's get your next one thank
you thank you this dude means so much to
me look at look at how he look look how
well he's dressed this is my dog right
here
and you're looking pretty flat tonight
too thank you matching shoes with the
soles what can we expect tonight because
you're taking the stage as well correct
great greatness greatness just wait on
it jack i need a little more to give the
people besides greatness what do you
want to know i want to get spill some
tea we let the performance speak we let
the music speak i could tell you about
it but i'd rather show you okay fair
enough these collaborations
i feel like who all have you not
collaborated with that you would like to
still collaborate with in the near
future i was just telling them
andre three thousand
we'll see where it takes me andre three
thousands that's my hero so yeah i see
i've seen he's working he's cooking
again he's got verses coming out again
so i'm just sending this message out to
you know i admire you maybe we'll make
it happen no rush